welcome back this is the ben shapiro
show joining us on the line is
representative dan crenshaw he's
represented for texas second
congressional district he's also hosted
the podcast hold these truth and author
of fortitude american resilience in our
era of outrage of course he served in
afghanistan and then of course lost and
i being hit by an ied on a deployment
over there served 10 years in the navy
seals dan thanks so much for joining the
show good to talk to you yeah it's great
to be with you so dan obviously this is
one of the darkest weeks in modern
american foreign policy history
certainly of my lifetime i was born in
the 80s so i don't remember the fall of
saigon but the utter betrayal to which
the biden administration has now
subjected our allies in afghanistan and
also the complete surrender of the
entire country to the taliban with now
apparently no true ability to even do
anti-terror operations in the country
it's astonishing how badly this was
handled
it really is um
i think we're forgetting something too
it it's also a surrender of a
basic strategic deterrence
you know the reason we go into
afghanistan the reason we kept deploying
there this is something the american
people need to hear that they have not
heard for years but the reason we keep
going there is to prevent a terrorist
safe haven because that terrorist safe
haven is what caused 911 and so our goal
was yeah not just to go after the people
who did it but to prevent it from ever
happening again you know we're forward
deployed everywhere around the world and
yet for some reason the no more endless
wars crowd has singularly focused on
afghanistan and people cannot seem to
distinguish between nation building
which indeed is a waste in a place like
afghanistan but they can't distinguish
between that and a small residual force
that was basically keeping a stalemate
propping up the afghan governments
enough so that we don't see this kind of
terrorist safe even take place
and it's it's really astonishing that
we're in this
position but there's been bipartisan bad
decisions on this for a long time you
know a push by conservatives as well but
no more endless wars crowd who who deny
the reality of where where we're at i
mean but the reality is it's either this
outcome or a small residual force and
they never wanted to believe that they
always wanted to believe in this
fictional reality where you could have
it both ways with zero troop presence
and also a a stable enough afghanistan
where no terrorist safe havens are but
it's not true never has yeah dan this is
the part that drives me up an absolute
wall so we have heard i mean joe biden
just lied overtly yesterday he kept
saying over and over we'd have rows of
headstones at arlington national
cemetery that are we going to send
another generation over there to die the
united states has had a minimum troop
presence in afghanistan since 2014 when
nato shifted its mission we had 2500
troops in afghanistan we'd had zero
combat casualties since february 2020.
there is no way to overstate this i mean
the the fact that he was treating this
as quote unquote endless war when we had
stopped spending hundreds of billions of
dollars we were now spending about 45
billion dollars a year to have a minimum
troop presence there and to prop up the
afghan government and then that we were
working in close tandem with the afghan
military which was in fact incurring
serious casualties like joe biden
ripping on the afghan military to the
tune of these are all cowards who ran
away when it's perfectly obvious what
happened here the afghan military
underwent 55 000 deaths over the last
seven years and the united states
military underwent under 100 deaths over
the last seven years in in the way of
combat here and yet the idea here from
joe biden is that the best possible
policy here was to withdraw all of the
bases of support upon which the afghan
military was relying we removed all air
support we took away all of the civilian
contractors were even fixing their
planes and so is it any wonder that the
afghan military collapsed overnight
no and this is a great point to bring up
look at they have sacrificed but i
fought with these people but i'll never
forget this story we did a mission uh
back when i was deployed there and this
was a simpler mission than we normally
did usually we flew in by helicopter to
insert but this time we drove
and we drove our m raps and they drove
their humvees and
we went and did our thing and and we
were talking about it afterwards we said
you know you guys have to be able to do
this on your own one day
and they asked us a very simple question
they said would you go do it with the
trucks that we have would you go do this
and we had to answer honestly nope no we
would not
because it's too dangerous to do it in
your trucks they're not as well armored
as ours so okay i get the point and the
point is with a minimal backup with with
minimal
assistance
the afghan army could continue that
stalemate with the taliban which as far
as
strategic national security interests
are concerned that's what america wants
okay we what we want is to deny a
terrorist safe haven i can't say that
enough and it was never told to the
american people that way and that's
really unfortunate what we've done is
basically told a drowning man to learn
how to swim while we pull away his life
raft
you know what it it it's not actually a
fair fight between the afghan army and
the taliban the taliban are an
insurgency they play by no rule they'll
kill civilians they'll hide among
civilians it's a completely different
way of warfare it's not like they're
fighting a conventional force and so it
really is insulting to them to to to
have expected this um it's also that
they're a brand new country we keep
saying oh we spent all this money in 20
years of training how come they're not
just like navy seals well they aren't i
mean they don't have the foundations
they don't have cultural foundations of
warfare they don't have
you know you sure it's a warrior culture
in a sense but not in a traditional
sense at all not the way that americans
have they don't have the logistical
foundations and they don't have a way to
pay their their soldiers this is what we
were taking care of and again at fairly
minimal costs
while while also providing a strategic
natural national interest i think look
just a few days ago we had the ability
to have bases that aircraft is stationed
a few hundred miles away from china and
iran
you think this is important this is
important stuff uh while also again
denying a terrorist space agency between
representative dan crenshaw who of
course served in afghanistan with the
navy seals so dan you know the this is a
bigger point that you're making here
which is the geostrategic points there's
the tactical point here which is this is
a complete failure we ended up giving
billions of dollars in equipment to
literally the worst people on earth
but then there's the geostrategic point
and that is that american foreign policy
is reliant on two basic mainstays one
that we are a good ally and two that we
are a horrifically bad enemy that if you
cross us we will break you and if you
ally with us we will defend you and we
have in us in one stroke basically
undermine both of those we have now
abandoned tens of thousands of our
allies in afghanistan hell we've
abandoned ten thousand americans in
afghanistan at this point without any
plan to get them out and at the same
time we have now conveyed to the rest of
the world that if we choose we'll just
pull out and leave you to die at a
moment's notice i mean we've already
done this to the kurds we've already
done this to the people of hong kong and
the west has more more broadly we've
already done this to the people of iran
the people of cuba like how many more
allies is the united states going to
betray before a bunch of people start
saying okay well maybe we're just going
to have to you know be conciliatory with
america's enemies china knows this
russia knows this iran knows this which
is why they are all on the marsh right
now
yeah that's exactly right and it's
extremely disappointing for american
prestige it's extremely damaging
um the potential future alliances that
we may need to
um
may need to establish
you know and there's this there's a bit
of a mythology out there that
especially from the no more endless wars
crowd that no we're we're not mad that
biden pulled out we're we're mad at how
we did it if we you know we would have
done it differently well i would say how
exactly
i mean so there's certainly improvements
here i mean what the bind administration
could have done much differently was at
least protect american citizens to get
them out first in a more orderly fashion
the us ambassador to in kabul needs to
be fired and resigned in shame you know
he actually requested to be pulled out
uh before embassy staff had even left he
wanted to abandon his post secretary of
state needs to needs to resign um based
on these actions as well so
you know there are some improvements
there but but let me be very clear about
something
if your goal was to go to zero troops
this was going to happen
now it happened faster than we thought
but it was always going to happen
and that strategic deterrence that
strategic national interest that we have
was always going to end up like this if
you went to zero troops and like you
said earlier
our cost was minimal there is a
difference between nation building and a
residual security force our cost was
minimal with very few troops there
providing the backup the afghan
government needed
and at a very low cost to us in both
lives and money and um it's to throw
that all away basically for the sake of
an emotional slogan bring the troops
home right because it makes us feel good
well facts don't care about your
feelings ben as you know
and uh this is exactly a good case study
for that yeah dan one of the things that
we've seen immediately is china
recognizing the taliban uh they want to
go into the rare earth's metals business
with the taliban meanwhile they're
openly threatening taiwan at this point
i mean they held a joint military
exercise uh on the outskirts of taiwan
they're already having their their
newspapers uh prince put out threats
about taiwan and if you're taiwan at
this point you got to be thinking like
what if china moves on us are we going
to see something similar to what we saw
in hong kong with taiwan where the
taiwanese people say well maybe the best
move we can make here is to elect some
sort of government that is friendlier to
the chinese government to try and reach
some sort of approach mon rather than
relying on the united states for backup
because again the united states has not
been a reliable partner here whether we
are talking about the united states
standing by while the well the russians
invaded crimea or whether we're talking
about the takeover of hong kong or now
whether we're talking about the complete
taliban takeover afghanistan
yeah in the taiwan situation is very
precarious and i'm deeply worried that
the chinese are going to test fight it
on this one
um but like americans need to have some
introspection here we need to decide who
we want to be are we are we the leaders
of the world or not and know that
doesn't mean world police but it is an
honest assessment of what defense and
national security actually mean
it seems to me that there's a lot of
people and again i'm going to pin this
right back of a no more endless wars
crowd it seems to me that they think
that national defense means like lining
up navy seals along our beaches in
california
surrounding our shorelines with navy
ships and just waiting for the enemy to
come you know looking out over the
horizon with binoculars defending the
country that's not actually how it works
in the real world in the real world you
need forward deployed presence and you
need to build alliances and those
alliances have to be
established and reassuring and
consistent
and if you don't ha and yes there's a
cost to that but there's also quite an
enormous benefit and
i i i don't know where we went wrong on
this um i i i
i think the american public is i think
the
pendulum has swung so far in the wrong
direction because we were rightfully
sick of
i think the wasteful nation building
that occurred in afghanistan
but we have to get back to i think a
sense of normal and stop looking at
foreign policy with pure emotion and
look at it with realism again a lot of
people say well well it was it was a
pointless war it wasn't wasn't going
anywhere look at the soviets look at the
british it's all the same thing and i
think
okay that's fine but
your the premise of your argument
seems to be that well i wish i lived in
a different reality
but i have to live in the real world and
especially with some responsibility as a
policy maker we have to live in the real
world
and in the real world there was always
two options here
uh this outcome or a small residual
force
and anybody who denies that is lying to
himself
yeah danny it really is a devastating
day for american prestige around the
world again um we are not a good ally to
our allies at this point we are we're
apparently not a particularly formidable
enemy to a lot of our enemies
and the image that is now rocking around
the world of a bunch of eighth century
barbarians uh storming the american
embassy which we built at the cost of
some seven hundred million dollars uh is
uh is going to be taken up by terrorists
around the world they're already stories
that they are doing just that uh it is
it is perfectly predictable it is really
really ugly um but it is it is not at
all surprising the only thing surprising
here is that anybody thought it would
end differently including apparently the
president of the united states it's
representative dan crenshaw texas
appreciate your time on what is a very
dark week for the united states or